well good evening from London and
welcome to Pittsburgh on a sense of
breaking news in the last couple of
hours 15 months ago Alec Baldwin shot
dead a female cinematographer on the set
of rust a movie he was starring in and
producing the death of Helena Hutchins
is one of the most appalling tragedies
in Hollywood history now there was no
doubt that it was an accident but Helena
Hutchins died leaving behind a
grief-stricken husband and a young child
and the person holding the gun that
fired a bullet that killed her was Ali
Baldwin it was him that did that he
fired the bullet into his co-worker's
Bud body and snuffed out her life nobody
else's hands weren't even near the gun
but since that tragic day Baldwin's been
the epitome of Hollywood arrogance he's
embarked on a woeful self-pitying PR
tour that felt cynically designed to
make people feel he was just as much of
a victim as the woman he killed he's
repeatedly spewed indignant denial of
any responsibility to his millions of
followers on social media and in a
succession of Television interviews
here's what he told ABC News
do you feel guilt no no I feel that
there is I I feel that that that that
someone is responsible for what happened
and I can't say who that is but I know
it's not me no guilt at all even though
he was literally holding the gun that
fired the bullet that killed this woman
not a shred of personal responsibility
accountability or guilt here he is
addressing his fans
I wanted to take a moment to
say thank you to all of the people who
sent me such kind words and uh
you know best wishes and strength and
hope and prayers and so forth and
thoughts and lots of encouragement and
lots of really really great
um
sentiments from so many people I got
hundreds hundreds of emails from friends
and family and colleagues and people
that I
and some I hadn't heard from in quite a
while to send me a
strength and good wishes and so forth
and I'm very grateful for that I want to
say thank you to everybody and online on
Instagram many people commenting
sorry
you haven't just won an Oscar
I saw that speech sounded like didn't it
an Oscar Redemption speech
no this is real life it's not a film a
young woman was killed
well today Santa Fe prosecutors
announced that he Alec Baldwin and the
film's armorer a young woman called
Hannah Gutierrez read will be charged
with involuntary manslaughter both face
up to 18 months in jail if they're
convicted but Baldwin should a form
issued a statement through his attorney
striking a familiar tone
this decision distorts something that
hutchin's tragic death represents a
terrible miscarriage of Justice his
lawyers said Mr Baldwin had no reason to
believe there was a live bullet in the
gun or anywhere on the movie Set we will
fight these charges and we will win well
we'll see about that because that's not
what the prosecutor thinks here's what
the prosecutor said
we've talked to many actors
um A-list and otherwise that have said
that they always check their guns or
they have someone check it in front of
them so it's not an actor doesn't get a
free pass just because they're an actor
and that's what's so important is that
we're saying here in New Mexico
everyone's equal under the law everyone
has to follow their duties and do what's
right and take that safety into account
so that this doesn't ever happen again
well that's right that's what I hear
from actors too they all check if
they're firing a firearm in any capacity
on a movie set they all check just for
their own sake never mind anybody else's
there's no live ammunition or anything
wrong with this weapon that they're
using Alec Baldwin's done a lot of
talking a lot of self-protective talking
a lot of spinning a lot of denial of any
accountability or responsibility well
his next words on this matter will be in
a court of law
let's discuss uh Baldwin's legal fight
we've got some American legal experts
coming shortly but I want to talk first
of all to lawyer Paula Roan Adrian talk
to the international editor Isabell
oakshot and talk to your presenter
Richard Tice this is a very emotive
story Richard
but it is hard I think you've got
Classic Hollywood response to a real
story you've got a kind of almost
fictional response like he's in a movie
Alec Baldwin and all that really matters
is that he comes through triumphant in
some way I.E without any blame for any
of this and yet at the heart of it is a
real woman really killed absolutely but
there are two separate things there's
his shocking appalling totally
inexcusable response as you've just
explained there but the reality is this
is a tragic tragic accident and as I
understand you never have liveab live
ammunition on a set so why on Earth
would he expect that there would be I
think what it shows though is this is
classic America someone's always to
blame you've got to sue someone you've
got to put him in jail I think that's
the wrong approach it's a tragic
accident learn from it make sure For
Heaven's Sake it never never happens
again but why go through all of this
process I just think that's I think his
his response has been completely
intensive but what do you achieve by
well actually what you achieve what you
achieve is for the poor woman's husband
and their young child uh what you
achieve is is accountability for the
death of this woman yeah I mean to me
sorry she was killed because there was a
complete breakdown of safety on the set
and I think probably it wasn't just the
star of the movie he was also a
co-producer of the movie and has
produced the responsibilities for what
is going on so that feels to me like the
charge is the wrong one
um I think you will know because
involuntary manslaughter means that you
kill somebody we didn't deliberately
mean to it I think you were uni harsh on
him I I mean really I accept that his PR
skills lead some leave something to be
desired I think his responses there are
pretty woeful and undoubtedly a part of
the reason he is where he is now facing
these charges but at the end of the day
you've got an actor on a set he must
have been in this position a thousand
times before he had no reason to expect
that gun was loaded someone handed him a
loaded gun hean was entitled to assume
that it was for the for the for the film
that it wasn't loaded with ammunition
and he accidentally do you make
assumptions when you're dealing with
statement that we just listened to but
actually on film sets there is a
procedure and that most actors in that
situation do make a final check
themselves but also in most film sets
there's never ever live ammunition right
anywhere near the film but again why
would it again he is a producer with
responsibility for that as well